all right so last week Tommy Lehren told
us that the people of West Hollywood
California were not exactly friendly
when she asked him about immigration so
Tommy went back to West Hollywood to ask
people well what the problem is with Fox
News and people like me and her take a
look you already get your news from nut
Fox not the biggest fan where do you get
your news
um see unit never Fox News I'm not a
really a big fan of Fox News I just
don't feel like I guess they're speaking
to me and you're speaking to me
literally but as far as their messages I
don't think they're speaking to me and
my peers you walk past me you said oh
there's Fox News you had a reaction you
saw the mic what do you think of Fox's
no thoughts no he had some thoughts no I
mean I'm not trying to get you here I
really want to know I tend to get my
news from the middle not not real
liberal not a real conservative
have you ever seen my videos on Facebook
I have what do you think when my videos
come across your feet I give everybody a
chance I'll listen I respect every
opinion and you know love will conquer
all they told me that this place is
about love and tolerance and welcoming
but apparently not a fair Republican
that is not the case so you see me out
here you know who I am you call me Tammy
that's fine well let's put that behind
us you know we're gonna move on from
that but you sought me out here where
the Fox News Mike what do you think
about Fox News I don't like it and I
don't really like a lot of your anchors
what you think about Sean Hannity I
think that Sean Hannity is extremely
interesting of a person what do you mean
by I mean just an interesting person
it's a guy with a lot of inner and outer
demons he's an unfortunate person to
have in the news environment
[Music]
isn't that weird that the area that
socity loving taller and welcome to
arrow and it's not lovely tolerant if
it's anomaly you think West Hollywood's
an anomaly yeah because there are always
song about love and acceptance but it's
only when your views match their views
every news source is biased now and I
want to get there was two sides to every
story and then there's the truth so if
you watch them all then you can get
together you actually get even crazier I
get my comedy from Fox News and I get my
news from comedians I just want to go
back to what you said though when you
first saw me you could help yourself you
had to call me Tam do you think that was
100% respectful I'm sorry
that whatever we're gonna respect each
other I mean I would never call you
someone outside of your name if I didn't
even know you
well baristas got my name on all the
time so you deliberately got mine wrong
to be me right I'm sorry we don't have a
lot of fans here FoxNews contributed
Tommy Larry wait a minute did he say I
have inner and outer demons yeah I'm not
sure I didn't really hear what your your
inner or your outward demons were but
you know they also said that you and I
are both problematic Fox News is
problematic but yet many of them don't
watch Fox News so I think that they're
just guessing I'm not sure Sean did you
get anybody that like this I didn't see
one person that like this they couldn't
be vocal about it that's the same thing
though there are a lot of people
actually even in West Hollywood that are
supporters of this president but they
wouldn't even dare wear a red baseball
cap
not even a make America great again hat
but even a red baseball cap they told me
that they wouldn't even dare wear that
in West Hollywood because the
repercussions would be very severe they
don't have any friends they would be
turned away I got a great idea for next
week go back to West Hollywood alright
sorry you know it's I'm so easy to give
the assignments here as I sit in the
comfort of the mini studio you got to go
back and you got it we're a great make
America great again hat and you got to
offer them for free to people that would
be great are you willing to do that oh I
will do it a hundred percent
I am absolutely you know you heard it
here first I'm gonna go back to West
Hollywood I'm gonna do just that I even
have a Trump 45 Jersey that I'm gonna
wear I think I should
to celebrate the one year of his
inauguration I think that's exactly what
we should do Shawn let's celebrate one
year of President Trump and I will go
back to West Hollywood all right wait a
minute now I got send it to me I'll say
I got to get it signed you got to get
the Hat and the jersey sign first then
we'll send you and you can say this is
really signed by the president and see
what they do or will Forge your
signature just to make one will tell
them the truth after and then because we
don't have time and then you could say
would you like a presidential sign cap
and then it's not really signed after
they give their response how's that I
almost sound like fake new CNN security
are you gonna send with me hey okay
we'll work I'll get you a real one how's
that gonna have a lot of fun Shawn all
right Tommy great work thank you